the wildfires in Maui have been
absolutely devastating 114 people
already confirmed dead an additional
thousand missing the Island's most
historic town the original capital of
the Hawaiian Kingdom has been burned to
the ground
the main theory of how the fires started
the one that you have most likely heard
because it's the favorite of the
establishment media is that it was
caused by catastrophic climate change
which of course it was not because
catastrophic climate change or global
warming or global cooling or whatever
they're going to call it tomorrow is not
real
none of the apocalyptic predictions that
the environmentalist zealots have
predicted since the 70s have come true
the world has not ended humans haven't
starved Nations have not been wiped away
even the polar bears are doing fine
more to the point
extremely slow and subtle changes in
temperature even if they were reliably
occurring do not cause massive fires in
multiple locations at once
a slightly more likely Theory as to the
origin of the fires is that the Hawaiian
Electrical Company knew of a wildfire
threat but waited years to act
four years ago Hawaiian electrical
declared that it had to do more to
prevent its power lines from spraying
Sparks that could potentially cause
wildfires but they didn't do anything to
fix it ironically because the company
was devoting all of its focus to Green
energy production that did nothing but
exacerbate the threat
but even that theory is weak compared to
the most likely culprit not just the
most likely culprit in my mind but
apparently in the mind of Hawaiian
officials and that's arson
for years now people have intentionally
set fires all over Maui as Maui Mayor
Michael Victorino noted just last year
fire and police suspect someone is
intentionally setting them
just a couple weeks ago Hawaiian police
responded to two fires on Maui one
started by an unattended cooking fire
the other apparently intentionally set
shortly after which point according to
investigators quote a male operating a
green all-terrain vehicle was seen
leaving the area and who would do such a
thing
we can't say for certain who might have
done it here but we can say for certain
the answer to who would do such a thing
and the answer is environmentalists
because here we are this is from the
Department of Homeland Security
Department of Homeland Security has
observed for decades that radical
environmentalists constantly start fires
all over the country
between 1995 and 2010 environmentalist
groups set off at least 239 arsons and
bombings in the United States
they do this because people are not
taking the theoretical threat of climate
change seriously enough so they make
that theoretical threat practical by
setting the fires themselves
it's not just the environmentalists
this is what leftists always do this is
how all ideologues behave when their
theories don't line up with reality I
once gave a talk at Loyola Marymount in
La about halfway through the talk a
group of black activists marched in with
duct tape over their mouths to protest
their point was that they had all been
silenced by white supremacy
but they hadn't
in fact when they walked in I offered
them the microphone and they didn't take
it because they couldn't take it not one
of them had been silenced
so they needed to justify their Theory
by silencing themselves
Jesse Smollett could not get attacked by
a conservative in Chicago he couldn't
find a conservative in Chicago
so he attacked himself the list of
liberal hoaxes in recent years would
take up a whole week of shows to go
through
the world is not as bad as the radicals
say that fact which should be a cause
for celebration infuriates them because
some people would rather watch the world
burn they'd rather burn the world down
themselves than admit that their
theories are wrong
I'm Michael knowlesus the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by genyourself skin care
get your Genius almost popular package
right now
for over seventy seven zero percent off
geniusell.com Knowles
we got Fat Bottom Girls coming up on the
show we'll get to that in just a second
I'll leave that kind of vague first
though
how do you like the new digs if you're
listening right now on RSS or apple
podcast you you can't see it we have
after two years
two years gotten a new set
some 24 months ago the daily wire said
Michael we want to build you a new set
and then they banished me to a broom
closet
at a desk made of cardboard in front of
a sheet of paper
for the ensuing 24 months now though
guys
they did a great job I can't complain
about the two years they they made the
set so perfectly my favorite thing about
this set
is that it has been so tailor-made to
every desire impulse even fleeting
thought that I have that if Ben ever
gets his way and cans me around here
they won't be able to reuse the set
no one else could use I think I would
take the set with me so wonderful to be
here in the new digs with all of you
in wonderful
sort of sort of wonderful to see
liberals admitting that they were wrong
being proven wrong again and again here
we have Jake Tapper on CNN
admitting that when it comes to the
hunter Biden crooked business deals
Donald Trump was right Joe Biden was
wrong Glenn Kessler from The Washington
Post had a fact check about Joe Biden
from earlier this month
um noting that Hunter Biden admitted in
court in July that he was in fact paid
substantial sums from Chinese companies
Kessler wrote Hunter Biden reported
nearly 2.4 million in income in 2017 and
2.2 million in income in 2018 most of
which came from Chinese or Ukrainian
interests but this and this directly
goes against what Joe Biden said in the
debate in 2020 with Donald Trump take a
listen
my son has not made money in terms of
this thing about what are you talking
about China once you amount of that
President he made a fortune in Ukraine
in China in mosque that is simply
various other places
so it's from two different debates but I
mean Trump was right I mean he did make
a fortune from China and Joe Biden was
wrong I don't know that he was lying
about it he might not have been told by
Hunter but this blind spot is a problem
it's a problem one because Republicans
aren't going to let it go that's for
sure that's the problem the problem is
these Republicans keep talking about it
actually in their mind that is the
problem and this is why I say it's only
sort of nice to see the Liberals admit
they were wrong because this is an
extremely
calculated admission
this is what's called a limited hangout
what is what is Tapper admitting here
what is CNN admitting okay Trump was
right
Hunter had some crooked deals in China
and Joe he might not have been lying he
just he might not have even known about
them we know for a fact he knew about
them you know how we know that we he
knew about them is we have handwritten
notes from Joe Biden to Hunter's
business partner because we know that
Joe Biden when vice president invited
Hunter's business partner to White House
functions with the president of China
because we know that Joe Biden got on 20
plus calls with Hunter's crooked
business associates
because we know that Joe Biden was
arranging meetings with the president of
Ukraine to hook up Hunter and we know
that Joe Biden was doing it using
pseudonyms that's what came out last
week Joe Biden had secret email
addresses with fake names
Robert Ware uh sorry Robert L Peters and
Robin Ware and all sorts of other
permutations of those names
so why is Tapper in CNN why are they
admitting this
it's a limited hangout a limited hangout
is a tactic usually associated with
Espionage but it's a broader political
tactic which is when you get caught when
they get you dead to rights there is no
way to continue to deny plausibly some
action that you want to cover up
you just give them a little bit you
admit to a minor part of the crime or
transgression that you're being accused
of so that you can continue to cover up
the rest and in fact deflect from
distract from the rest of it so what are
they distracting from here Tapper is
distracting from the fact that we know
for a fact Joe Biden knew about this
Tapper is distracting from the fact that
the House Republicans just got proof
that Biden was conducting this business
with fake names so obviously shows
intention shows calculation shows
deliberation and deceit the other thing
he's distracting from is the breaking
news report that came out on Friday
which is that Biden wasn't the only
member of the Obama Administration using
pseudonymous email addresses
and not pseudonyms in the way that Mitt
Romney was using a pseudonym Mitt Romney
got caught using a pseudonym on Twitter
Pierre delecto and it was so that he
could like and reply to different
journalists and stuff
it was silly he was he was liking and
replying to some of his colleagues in
Congress meant nothing it was just a
Pastime for him for These Guys these
Obama administration officials they were
coordinating crooked business deals with
major oligarchs and world leaders and
who were the who were the Obama
Administration officials were they
low-level people no we found out that
the people who used Alias email
addresses were Lisa Jackson EPA
administrator Loretta Lynch super
crooked attorney general for Obama Eric
Holder also crooked attorney general for
Obama Barack Obama himself used a
pseudonymous email address as did
Hillary but I'm going to give both of
them a little pass here and I'm going to
give them a pass because the Obama and
Hillary pseudonymous email addresses
were things like you know
bo357 that's not the precise one but it
was you know H Rod 352 what various
versions of their own names so I don't
really count that in the same category
people like Lynch holder Jackson Joe
Biden when he was vice president they
were using completely invented
identities obviously not just to of void
foia requests and oversight in a a way
where you could have plausible
deniability that you were doing it
intentionally but in a way that was
crafted to avoid any oversight because
they don't want people poking into their
crooked business dealings
okay I guess Trump trump was right about
Hunter yeah you bet he was right about
Hunter he was right about the rest of it
too
don't be satisfied with the limited
hangout keep on digging House
Republicans and Republican voters
now speaking of Republican voters we
have a debate coming up we'll get to
that in one second first though in our
crazy political order you want to
protect your assets
you gotta check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 as central
banks in countries like China India and
Australia begin transitioning to a
digital currency the Federal Reserve has
been contemplating the same for the U.S
with a digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make officials could even prohibit you
from purchasing certain products or
easily freeze or seize part or all of
your money these are some of the reasons
concerned Americans reach out to Birch
gold they want to have a physical asset
like gold that is independent of the US
dollar you can protect your IRA or 401K
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold historically gold has been a safe
haven in times of high uncertainty which
is right now learn if gold is right for
you too text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98 they will send you a free info kit
on gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help EU
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will will be nice to have some gold to
depend upon again text Knowles Canada
wbles to 98.98 98
speaking of trump we got news out now
this according to a report from The New
York Times so take it with a grain of
salt but they're probably right here
Trump is going to skip the GOP debate
we've all been waiting he said he
wouldn't go to the debate he wouldn't
sign the Loyalty pledge that the RNC was
trying to get him to sign but now it
seems likely he will skip that GOP
debate and instead have a one-on-one
interview with Tucker Carlson
and maybe you love Trump
and maybe you hate Trump
but I want you for just a moment to try
to put your feelings however strong
aside and just look at this as though
you were a strategist advising Donald
Trump
this is obviously the smart thing to do
obviously
you might not like it because you want
Trump to show up to the debate stage
either because it'll be very
entertaining and you like him or because
you like DeSantis or somebody and you
you want DeSantis to have a shot at
hitting him but
this is obviously the right thing to do
according to virtually every poll
GOP voters prefer Donald Trump to the
entire rest of the field combined Grant
of virtually every major poll that one
outlier is Reuters which has him
slightly below 50 support the rest of
them that being listed on the realtor
politics average have trumpet over 50
support so if Trump has the majority of
primary voters locked up according to
pretty much every poll why would he give
his opponents the opportunity to take
him down at a debate doesn't make
political sense but furthermore
he says okay the the voters like me more
than they like the rest of the field
okay so I'm gonna go do my own thing
furthermore
which group or organization do GOP
voters prefer the primary base
Tucker Carlson or Fox News which is
hosting the debate
easy answer
you might say well Fox still gets
viewership Fox still yeah sure it does
in terms of Republican primary voters
who inspires more loyalty and affection
Tucker Carlson or Fox News Tucker for
sure especially after fox fire Tucker
it makes perfect sense for Trump to skip
this thing now maybe
this this harms Trump's poll numbers
maybe the the debate opponents who show
up the second tier who show up to the
debate in Milwaukee maybe they don't
just spend the whole time sniping at
each other and they actually go after
Trump and maybe somehow that knocks down
his poll numbers well then I guess
Trump's gonna have to show up for the
second debate but if you were advising
him right now on the first debate I
don't see how you could possibly advise
him to show up
now speaking of those other candidates
Ron DeSantis who's still the number two
guy in the race got in a little bit of
trouble
over the weekend because he had an
interview with Will Witt arpel will Whit
formerly of Prager you now the Florida
standard in which DeSantis described
Trump voters as listless vessels
we have a strand in our in our party
that views
supporting Trump as whether you are
um a rhino or not and so you could be
the most conservative person since
sliced bread unless you're kissing his
rear end they will somehow call you a
rhino so it's been totally detached from
principle and what you actually believe
in results and it's more about you know
just what faction you happen to do so
there'll be people who are huge Trump
supporters like in Congress who have
like incredibly liberal left-wing
records that that's really just
atrocious and yet they're viewed as by
by some of these folks as like as like
really really good then you have other
people you know like a congressman chip
Roy who's endorsed me Congressman Thomas
Massey these guys have records of
principal fighting the swamp that are
second to none and yet they will be
attacked by some of these people and and
called rhinos so it's just been totally
detached from any type of substance and
ultimately but let's put pause it right
there okay he has more to say which is
important but as for what the governor
said up till that point
he's basically right his observation is
right
that there are very liberal republicans
in Congress who because they support
Trump
get praise and adulation from the more
conservative elements of the GOP base
well that seems crazy doesn't it whereas
you get a chip Roy or you get a Thomas
Massey or other people who are have
pretty decent Bona fides as right
Wingers Rock ribbed people and they get
attacked by the more conservative
wing of the GOP and they get lumped in
with the more liberal wing of the GOP
and it's all based on whether or not you
support Trump
that is more indicative of whether
you're considered a hard right-winger or
a squishy liberal type then one's voting
record or the statements that one makes
on various policy issues that part is
true now where DeSantis I think goes
wrong is in his explanation of this a
movement can't be about the personality
of one individual the movement has got
to be about what are you trying to
achieve on behalf of the American people
and that's got to be based in principle
uh because if you're not rooted in
principle uh if all we are is listless
vessels that's just supposed to follow
you know whatever happens to come down
the pike on Truth social every morning
that that's not going to be a durable
movement
would that it were so simple Governor
would that it were so simple but first
of all
not a not a good idea to insult the
primary base and the way he does it here
it's not as bad as the deplorables
comment as some people are suggesting it
was it's not as bad as the bitter
Klinger's argument in fact DeSantis is
lumping himself in there he's saying
look if we all do this we can serve as
we Republicans then we're going to be
listless vessels and we're not going to
do very well okay fair enough
the thing that he gets wrong here is
that politics is not just about the
message it's also about the messenger
this gets back to a basic observation
from the Canadian Communications
theorist Marshall mcluhan
the medium is the message
the medium is the message in politics
especially that's the case because we're
electing men we're not just electing
robots we're not just electing blank
slates or we're not just electing five
bullet point manifestos on the back of a
napkin we're electing living breathing
men with flesh and blood who walk around
and who say things and who do have
personalities
politics is largely about personality
and a problem for desantises because
he's the anti-trump candidate he's
attracted a lot of support from the
squishy liberal side of the party I
don't think DeSantis has particular
affection for the squishy liberal side
of the party over the conservative side
but that's just the way these sort of
things shake out you think about if you
only voted on issues let's say you were
an abortion
voter you're purely pro-life that's the
only issue you cared about
you'd probably vote for Mike Pence
right Mike Pence has a very very
consistent record of being pro-life much
more so than Donald Trump
and Donald Trump has spoken favorably of
abortion rights rights quote unquote in
his career
and yet Trump got more done
on abortion than Mike Pence did Mike
Pence was part of that because he was
the vice president of the administration
but you don't just vote on issues you
vote on the whole thing and the reason
the personality matters is because
Donald Trump is viewed by the liberal
establishment as a wrench into the
system that's why they're Prosecuting
him over nothing that's why they're
making up these ridiculous excuses to
prosecute him
because the very fact of electing this
guy was such a middle finger to the
system in 2016 that they can't take it
anymore and so that's why they tried to
undermine his administration based on BS
that they just didn't fabricated out of
whole cloth and that's why they're
they're trying to put it into an orange
jumpsuit now
so it's a little bit like the facts
don't care about your feelings thing
that's it's true that facts don't care
about your feelings exactly but politics
largely cares about your feelings and
that's why DeSantis though he's got a
great record and though he's got a great
program he's probably got a very
coherent political Vision he is going to
have to inspire personal loyalty based
on his personality if he wants to take
the number one spot in the race it's as
simple as that you've got to look good
and when you want to look good you got
to check out gen yourself right now go
to geniusell.com Knowles what do you see
when you look in the mirror do you see
dark spots well they're not going to go
away on their own you need help from
geniusell's Dark Spot Corrector here
just in time for the summer and for the
fall and for the winter all year round
the Dark Spot Corrector has not won but
three Cutting Edge ingredients goes to
work fast on sunspots dark spots liver
spots even old discoloration both on
your face and hands you will be amazed
at how quickly you see results you can
now now enjoy summer beach Sun barbecues
without embarrassing spots with genuine
cell you will see the results or your
money back no questions asked go to
genucel.com Knowles right now get your
dark spot corrector with the new genius
almost popular package and say goodbye
to those pesky spots tomorrow they're
offering free shipping free returns and
the best luxury skincare you've ever
used all for seventy seven zero percent
off all orders will also include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
geniusell.com Knowles
are you sick of lib corporations
dragging your beliefs through the mud
wash your hands of it with Jeremy's
brand new hand soap Jeremy's hand soap
is the perfect solution for everyday
grit and grime not to mention it smells
amazing as it is scented with green tea
and citrus ooh Jeremy's actually cares
about you so he didn't put any of that
paraben crap in his hand soap no sir not
only is it paraben free
it's also free of sulfates and Dei and
ESG as well plus it's not tested on
animals and it's made right here in the
USA Jeremy's hand soap is only tested on
Aliens not on humans not on not on
animals not on little bugs only
extraterrestrial aliens being held in
Mount Walsh's Studio what more could you
want from your hands up than to get
clean hands while keeping a clean
conscience do yourself a favor wash your
hands of hypocritical Libs once and for
all German's hand soap is the ideal
addition to your bathroom or kitchen
sink as you liberate your home from the
influence of woke companies go to
Jeremy's razors.com order your green tea
and citrus hand soap today
now we got some good news here
rare good news from the political order
but some good news a federal judge has
just determined that you cannot
copyright AI produced material
so if you if you logged on right now to
Mid Journey or chat gbt or whatever and
you had chat EBT write you a novel where
you had mid-journey make you a big
painting you can't copyright that
now maybe you were not trying to
copyright it but plenty of big studios
and corporations are trying to copyright
these things well uh apparently
copyright law according to this judge
has quote never stretched so far as to
protect Works generated by new forms of
technology operating absent any guiding
human hand great news from U.S District
Judge Beryl Howell who says that human
authorship is a Bedrock requirement for
copyright it's good news because we all
want to avoid the AI dystopia where
Terminator just comes around and starts
killing all of us and the way to avoid
the AI dystopia is not to whine about it
the way to avoid it is to pass laws and
because we don't really pass laws
anymore in this country the legislators
don't do that we just get bureaucrats
writing regulations and judges making
decisions well here especially because
the the judges are so powerful the
judges come in and said no
we're gonna we're going to stop the main
incentive for this AI Revolution and the
main incentive is money
this isn't this is an important fact
about the political order too
whenever people whine and complaint
whether it's the 2024 race whether it's
the the way that the Congress operates
whether it's the way that that new
regulations are passed
people whine and complain they say this
isn't fair and this isn't right and
Democrats are being Hypocrites and come
on where's the Justice where's the
very often especially in regimes that
become decadent and cynical money talks
and Bs walks and so if you want your
cultural change to have any sort of
teeth you're going to have to enshrine
it into law and make sure that it lines
up with financial incentives this is
good stuff
this is really good stuff
we you still human beings are still
necessary at least for now speaking of
art Queen one of my favorite rock bands
of all time
not like the biggest rock and roll
fanatic but you know one of my favorite
rock bands ever Queen
has just dropped one of its biggest hits
from its greatest hits collection the
new greatest hits collection for Queen
will not include Fat Bottom Girls oh
you're going to take me home tonight oh
down beside that red fire light oh won't
you let it all hang out Fat Bottom Girls
you make the rock and roll go round
that's gonna be out this song was
written in 1978 it's been a big hit ever
since it was written by Brian May who's
a big lib
worth pointing that out because I think
this is crucial here and it would appear
that the band hasn't made any statement
on it that the libs of Queen
and the record label have caved to the
woke people who have said that this song
is Politically Incorrect and that it's
mean to fat women or something like that
and you might be saying Michael that
explanation doesn't make any sense
because we live in the world of lizzo we
live in the world of body positivity
Fat Bottom Girls should be an Anthem
except Fat Bottom Girls is kind of a
cheeky funny song it's kind of making a
little bit of a joke about it
kind of like uh what's that song Lola
Lola you know who's a a dude but looks
like a chick or whatever you don't
really hear that song as much anymore
because it's kind of it's a song about
a certain
psychosexual phenomenon that we're not
allowed to talk about on YouTube but you
think well maybe you'd hear that song
more now as that ideological fad has
become more prevalent but no because
it's kind of making fun of it well here
Fat Bottom Girls is kind of making fun
of it but it shouldn't but shouldn't
that be positive too can't we
appropriate that term just like LGBT
activists have reappropriated queer it
doesn't hold on what's going on I'll
tell you exactly what's going on it's
the Catch-22 of woke culture
you see this if you're a white guy you
see this if you if you serve tacos at
your dinner party if you serve tacos at
your dinner party as a white person that
is cultural appropriation
if you don't serve tacos at your dinner
party as a white person that's cultural
Erasure
if you wear a sombrero and Cinco de Mayo
cultural appropriation if you don't
acknowledge Cinco de Mayo cultural
Erasure
those are two Mexican examples but they
go throughout the entire culture and so
here if you have a fun song about
slightly more corpulent Buxom women
uh
that would be
appropriation I guess that would be or
making light of this issue or making fun
or being derisive but if you don't it's
Erasure what do you do what do you do
you shut up that's what you do the
reason the reason the queen has to get
rid of the song is not because of this
the subject matter of the song The
Reason Queen has to get rid of the song
is because they're white guys
the nearest thing to a not white guy in
Queen was Freddie Mercury and he's been
dead for decades so they can't do it
it's not that this sort of thing cannot
be talked about it's that you can't talk
about it now getting back to money Joe
Biden
has just brought some great news out
this is I had missed this achievement of
his administration Joe Biden
has for the first time in many many
decades
decreased the national debt allegedly
unlike the last president in my first
two years in office even with all we've
done
I'm the first one to cut the federal
debt by one trillion seven hundred
billion dollars
one trillion 700 billion dollars cut one
trillion 700 billion dollars cut from
the debt since Biden took office except
actually since Biden took office the
debt has increased 4.175 trillion
dollars
so that's a Delta
of
five or six trillion dollars that's hmm
how do you reconcile those two things oh
Biden's just lying Biden has not cut the
debt at all he's massively increased it
according to
Moody's now what about the deficit so
maybe maybe Biden meant to say he's cut
the deficit rather than the debt right
the debt is just the total amount of
money that we owe the deficit
is how much more money we're spending
every year than the money that we're
taking in well according to Moody's
uh Biden's actions in his first two
years quote have undoubtedly resulted in
higher deficits not smaller ones
so Biden has increased the debt
massively he's increased the debt
massively by maintaining or according to
Moody's Analytics increasing the deficit
so what he said just isn't true it's
completely divorced from reality I I
couldn't even begin to tell you what he
was trying to say
so he's either a liar which he is
or he inadvertently got this wrong out
of incompetence he's also incompetent so
I don't know which of the two it is
either way though you might be saying
well how is this guy going to get
reelected he's running for office again
on not a lot of accomplishments and we
were talking about the importance of
personality when you're when you're
running for office well how is he going
to get elected if he seems incapacitated
because what other option do the
Democrats have
what other option do they have
he unless he actually dies in office or
on the campaign Trail this guy is going
to be the nominee he wants it he doesn't
like Kamala Harris he doesn't like booty
judge for goodness sakes he doesn't like
Gavin Newsom this guy has spent every
waking moment since he was two years old
maybe since he was in the womb figuring
out how to be president that's all he
wants in life
he's not going to just give it up unless
he's dragged out of there by his ankles
so he's going to be the nominee and if
he's the nominee and you're a Democrat
what are you going to do you're going to
vote for Trump probably not you probably
have a better shot at voting for Trump
than you do of voting for a standard GOP
type A Mitt Romney or a John McCain
because at least Trump is weird and
populist and upends GOP Orthodoxy on a
handful of policies at least but still
you're probably just going to vote for
bye you gonna vote for Cornell West
you're gonna no you're probably just
gonna vote for Biden so
even even if he gets everything wrong
that he says even if his
presidency is unsuccessful
if you were a Democrat why wouldn't you
vote for him you're going to vote for
orange Hitler the mango Mussolini that
the media have just spent seven years
telling you is the greatest threat ever
in the history of our country
even if DeSantis is the nominee you can
vote for DeSantis the Ron death santis
the killer of Ponte Vedra who who
slaughtered senior citizens during covid
according to the liberal media no who
are you gonna vote for
the vague they'll figure out something
about Vivek if somehow he's the nominee
no you're gonna vote for Biden even if
it's Weekend at Bernie's and they
streaming him up like a marionette now
speaking of Biden's in capacity I meant
to get to this last week this was this
was a minor political snafu and scandal
but but it's telling about this the
current state of affairs in the race
Karine Jean-Pierre accidentally posted a
tweet in the voice of Joe Biden Corrine
Jean-Pierre the press secretary tweeted
out or someone tweeted out from her
account quote
investing in America means investing in
all of America when I ran for president
I made a promise that I would leave no
part of the country behind
I don't think Korean Jean-Pierre ran for
president ever so this means that from
the White House
someone sent this from the wrong account
okay of course no one really thinks
green Jean Pier is running her own
account no one thinks Joe Biden is
running his own account no one thinks
that Joe Biden knows what Twitter is
the reason this kind of a little Gaff
matters is it
gives you another little hint of why at
least some people a substantial number
of people like Donald Trump
and why they even like his tweets which
are often extremely obnoxious and
sometimes kind of embarrassing
they like Trump and they like even the
Trump tweets because they know there's a
real person there there's a real guy and
it's Trump lying in bed Doom scrolling
at night just sending out crazy despite
the constant negative presco FeFe and
then he falls asleep it doesn't even
delete the tweet and it's kind of weird
and bizarre and maybe even a little bit
embarrassing but oh it's a real person
that uh that I can feel affection for
that I can be loyal to that I can expect
something from them to keep his promises
we hope that I that I can rally around
this is democratic politics folks
lowercase D
this is government of the People by the
people for the people so
we want people
it's a people business okay especially
when we're talking about the executive
which is one person and I think part of
the reason that you've got so much
political rot and malaise right now is
that we've we've divorced government of
the People by the people for the people
from the people from their desires
you'll you elect either party you get
more migration you get more foreign war
you get more Outsourcing of jobs you get
more debt you get more of the same stuff
that people aren't calling for but
that's what you get anyway
you in in the case of
of recent decades you elect people and
yet the ones who make the laws or the
unaccountable careers bureaucrats who
you can never kick out of office
and in recent decades you you get people
running for office
you don't feel any connection to them
the last president
other than in the days just after 9 11
when George Bush had a lot of Goodwill
anyway throughout the pitch at Yankee
Stadium throughout that perfect strike
people I think a lot of personal
Goodwill toward him but beyond that that
rare
historical moment right after we'd been
attacked the last president who inspired
this kind of personal loyalty
and a little bit of crossing the aisle
was Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan had that
real personal connection and uh
that's missing that's missing when you
could send out the same tweet from the
Press Sac or the president or who cares
the VP or the Secretary of this doesn't
matter it's all the same focus group
tested
nonsense political gobbledygook from an
establishment that is increasingly
unresponsive to
the people
now when you want to cut through some of
the red tape in the bureaucracy and
engage more with people when it comes to
your health care you got to check out
metashare right now go to medishare.com
Michael as a daily wire listener you are
not just informed you're handsome also
engaged and you value personal
responsibility Freedom or way of life
that is why we think that you will like
Medi share Medi share is a community
based approach to healthcare that lines
up with the principles that you believe
in your values matter with Medishare
your health care dollars won't be used
for medical procedures that don't line
up with your beliefs metashare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400 000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing for one another
members save up to fifty five zero
percent or more on their monthly health
care costs for limited time daily wire
listeners will get a 150 dollar gift
card when you join metashare to find out
more go to metashare.com Michael that is
metashare.com
Medi share.com slash Michael terms and
conditions apply my favorite comment on
Friday is from Mean Bean comedy who says
Michael I tried playing your yes or no
game with my girlfriend but she kept
getting upset when the women voting
questions came up I guess in one of the
packs because you know we have the
booster pack Now The Conspiracy Theory
pack for the yes or no game it's
available on daily wireshop it's
probably gonna sell out so if you want
it you should get it now but I guess one
of the questions is pertaining to
whether women should Vote or not and so
anyway the comment keeps going I tried
telling her to calm down I said she was
acting crazy and I even informed her
that she was acting like her mother any
ideas well look you've obviously studied
women you know exactly the things to do
and say to persuade them I don't know I
mean
you could ask them you could ask her if
she's forgot to take her pills today
you know you could um
you could tell her you're gonna go watch
the game with the guys and crack a few
beers and hopefully she's not as nuts
when you get back I don't you know yeah
all of these things usually calm women
down and get them to like you more so I
think you're on the right track
speaking of the race
we keep forgetting about this third
potential candidate in the race which is
Cornell West Cornell West is this
leftist professor he's been at Harvard
he's been at Princeton now he's
somewhere else but he's also running for
president
Cornell West
is running and the the liberal
establishment's trying to take him down
they're saying he has tax problems now
because they want him out of the race
because according to a new Emerson poll
if Cornell West is in the race and Trump
and Biden are the nominees then Trump is
going to win according to this poll and
don't forget Emerson is a liberal poll
and it's considered a good liberal poll
538 Nate Silver's outfit ranks Emerson
as a top poll in terms of reliability
shows that 42 percent of registered
voters would vote for Trump
over uh Joe Biden at West Cornell West
takes five percent of respondents and
another 13 percent are undecided so you
got a one percentage difference here but
Cornell West could give the election to
Trump now worth pointing out even if
West is not in the race even it's a
head-to-head matchup Trump still
according to Emerson has this razor thin
0.7 percent lead so for for all intents
and purposes it's a tie at 44. 12 of
respondents are up for grabs here
so even even people always think they
think a year and a half out now closer
to a year out they'll say look this is
how the race is going to shake out
there's going to be this guy's gonna be
the nominee and then if this guy's a
nominee then this is how these people
are going to vote and this and that and
this and that no one knows anything no
one knows anything you can't predict the
future
and it could take one Cornell West it
could take one Ralph Nader Ralph Nader
doesn't run for president in 2000 Al
Gore becomes the president
it could take one little nothing
totally unexpected blip to throw
the election
and what does the election matter we've
just been talking about how the
president doesn't actually have that
much power and the legislators don't
have that much power the Judiciary still
does though and the President appoints
the judges and we've got some great news
out of the fifth circuit fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals just ruled that
the abortion drug mifa pristone
should not be distributed through the
mail or prescribed via telemedicine
this is a ruling Unfortunately they
can't take effect until the Supreme
Court issues a ruling on the decision so
previously we covered this on the show
we've gotten a ruling from the U.S
District Judge Matthew Cox Merrick
who suspended the fda's approval of
Memphis this is just the chemical
abortion drug that that is
accounting for a huge number of
abortions already and in the future will
likely account for a huge number more of
the abortions especially as states begin
to Outlaw abortion in the wake of the
Dobbs decision so this federal judge
said the FDA should not approve this
thing This Is A Dangerous Drug it should
be taken off the market this appeals
court judge said no no it still gets
this FDA approval but you sh you can't
prescribe it through telemedicine and
you can't send it through the mail
the alliance defending Freedom which is
just a great organization fighting these
cases uh pointed out so the fifth
circuit rightly required the FDA to do
its job and restore crucial safeguards
for women and girls including ending
illegal mail order abortions the FDA
will finally be made to account for the
damage it caused to the health of
countless women and girls and the rule
of law by unlawfully removing every
meaningful Safeguard from the chemical
abortion drug regimen so young young
girls in many cases are getting these
extremely powerful dangerous drugs and
they're popping them to kill their
babies so they think that they can do it
without anybody noticing and they're
having all sorts of
unwanted side effects and and harms
increasingly the courts are going to be
where the wins are
this is one of the reasons that the left
is indicting Trump
you know I really like Trump as I've
made no secret about that fact but I
will totally
admit I think I've admitted more than
most Trump supporters and as much as
some of Trump's harshest critics that a
lot of
his policies were a little weird you
know the the jailbreak act that that uh
First Step act I thought was completely
insane the border wall did not entirely
get built and now now Biden is selling
off he's auctioning off unused portions
of the border wall that didn't happen I
I felt Trump could have done a lot more
on the sexual Revolution stuff or I
would have liked to have seen that I
would have he was doing very well on
trade with China but then that ended
when the covid stuff happened obviously
some of the covet policy was messed up
so I have his write a view of trump as
as possible
and I think the the liberals do too if
Trump had just been passing laws
tax cuts or something I don't think
they'd go after him quite so hard but he
was he was trying to upend policy and by
instituting his judges by by putting
them on the courts huge number of Judges
including the Supreme Court
he
had the most significant effect on
public policy of any Republican in our
lifetimes the guy got Roe v Wade over
ruled
and you might say well that was just the
courts yeah but the judges were
appointed by the president
and he appointed better judges than
previous Republican presidents
so
that's a big deal that's why they're
going after him increasingly you're
going to see that focus on the courts
speaking of the sexual Revolution this
is a story that I haven't seen a lot of
people talk about but
it's a it's a really good sign for the
culture and the sign is that Burning Man
ticket prices are collapsing you know
Burning Man
if you have never been you if you're
listening to the show you very likely
have never been to burning man maybe you
have but you probably know some big lib
or hippie who has been burning man is
this weird ritual every year where
people go out to the desert like a
bazillion people go to the desert and
they do a bunch of drugs and they have
sex with a lot of people and they move
around like weirdo hippies and they
worship this this Burning Idol
and people think of it as an artistic
event you know man or it's like kind of
a cultural it's like a fun like weird
cultural thing well it was a it was a
really big deal and now the tickets are
collapsing tickets
face value or 575 bucks and yet now
they're selling for as low as 139 bucks
parking passes used to be 150 now
they're being marked down to 105 bucks
we've never seen anything like this
what's going on is it an artistic shift
no it's not because that people don't
like the music as much anymore is it a
cultural shift
not exactly
it's a religious shift
because
Burning Man is a religious ritual
they literally worship a burning Idol
okay there's no there is virtually no
difference between what the hippies do
at Burning Man and what the apostate
perfidious Israelites did in the desert
when Moses went up the mountain and left
them alone to their own devices and they
started having all sorts of bacchanals
and worshiping a golden calf
there isn't virtually no difference
and forget about the Israelites for a
second shows you that even the most
serious monotheistic God's chosen people
can be so faithless but virtually every
Pagan Society throughout all of history
throughout the Hellenic world and
throughout the the uncivilized world too
this is what they do
they do a bunch of drugs and they have a
bunch of orgies and they worship
gigantic Idols that's what they do and
that's what they were doing here at
Burning Man and I think people just got
sick of it because religious fads come
and go false gods come and go
this is the wisdom of Bishop Fulton
Sheen who says that if you marry
yourself to the spirit of the world
you'll find the spirit of the age rather
you'll find yourself a widow in the next
so the Burning Man the false Burning Man
God
seems to be passing away there are other
false gods they're cropping up these
same weirdo new agey hippies are going
to go do some other bizarre ritual
that's going to involve a lot of drugs
and a lot of orgies not a lot of bizarre
activity but it's not going to be this
one this one's not going to endure only
true religion endures this is the line
of Hillary belloch who says the way that
he has to take it on faith that the
Catholic church is real that's divinely
instituted but if you don't believe it
the proof of its Divine institution is
that no other organization conducted
with such Neighbors in bacility would
have lasted a fortnight much less 2 000
years a lot longer
than Burning Man okay it's music Monday
Baby the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nulls Canada wlas check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
foreign
[Music]